dans cet atelier de couture des jeunes
se sont portés volontaires pour
fabriquer des vêtements et des masques
de protection pour le personnel
hospitalier qui fait face à une pénurie
sans précédent j'ai entendu parler de
cette initiative et je suis venu pour
aider pour que nous soyons en côte est
du pays et du personnel médical qui
veillent sur nous 24 heures sur 24
nous espérons que dieu fera disparaître
cette épidémie et mettra fin à ces
difficultés et nous espérons que le pays
sera en sécurité
nous demandons à tous ceux qui le
peuvent de se porter volontaire pour
nous rejoindre
en cette période de confinement
l'activité économique ralentit
conséquence de nombreux algériens manque
de ressources
certaines personnes âgées par exemple ne
peuvent plus sortir de chez elle pour
aller retirer de l'argent pour faire
face à cette situation des bénévoles
d'associations locales font du porte à
porte dans les rues d'alger pour offrir
une aide alimentaire aux plus démunis et
délivrer des messages de sensibilisation
aux gestes barrières
nous allons à la rencontre des personnes
qui ne peuvent pas quitter leur domicile
les personnes âgées qui ne peuvent pas
aller à la banque pour retirer de
l'argent tout cela nous leur disons de
rester chez eux pour éviter d'être
infecté par la maladie que nous
viendrons vers eux et leur apporte euros
l'aide alimentaire adéquat pour une
période de deux semaines la sécurité le
gouvernement a décidé d'allouer 91
millions d'euros à l'importation de
produits pharmaceutiques et
d'équipements de protection
de son côté le irak le mouvement de
contestation qui dure depuis 13 mois a
suspendu ces manifestations
hebdomadaires et privilégient désormais
une mobilisation sanitaire son nouveau
slogan se protéger pour que la
révolution est un avenir